guten morgen herr linkens sagen sie wie
konnte es überhaupt in ihrer kleinen
stadt zu einem derartigen ausbruch
kommen ja das ist die frage die viele
bürgermeistern viele verwaltungen
stellen
es gibt unterschiedliche gründe bei uns
in zusammenarbeit mit dem gesundheitsamt
ist erkennbar dass es unterschiedliche
größere veranstaltungen gab in einem
fall wohl eine beerdigung nicht in
unserer stadt an der aber was weil der
bürger teilgenommen haben und wohl auch
familienfeiern mit der folge dass gerade
größere familien betroffen sind wir
haben tatsächlich 75 positiv getestete
fälle die derzeit immer gehandelten 299
resultieren aus diesen incident faktor
in dem man die einwohner auf 100000
hochrechnet tatsächlich haben wir etwa
28.000 einwohner und 75 fälle positiv
was viel zu viel ist aber immerhin nicht
die 300 wie werden sie jetzt weiter
vorgehen wird es auch bei ihnen zum
lockt ankommen oder setzen sie erst mal
auf die eigenverantwortung der menschen
also entscheidungen für lok tore wären
wir nicht befugt ich glaube mich nicht
gerne auf unzuständigkeit aber wir sind
eine kreisangehörige stadt im raum
aachen und zuständig ist das
gesundheitsamt aber selbst das nicht
sondern in zusammenarbeit mit dem
gesundheitsministerium des landes
nordrhein westfalen in düsseldorf
also das als ein lockdown derzeit nicht
erkennbar ist wie ihr unternehmen sehr
sehr viel wir haben zum beispiel in
unserer größenordnung drei gruppen von
mitarbeitern jeden tag vor allen dingen
auch abends spät im einsatz
die gaststätten kontrollieren die
öffentliche plätze kontrollieren und
vieles bewirken insbesondere auch die
einsicht unserer bürger die zeiten wo
die geistigen geschlossen werden sollen
23 uhr geehrten eingehalten und wir
erkennen eine große identifikation
unserer bürger was ganz wichtig ist und
ich
aber auch zum erfolg führen wird ist
dass wir die positiv getesteten personen
kontrollieren ob sie tatsächlich
quarantäne beachten ob sie zu hause sind
und nicht sich im freien bewegen und
möglicherweise andere anstecken wie
kontrollieren sie denn das haben sie
denn dafür auch genug personal denn dann
ist das ist ja ganz auf das problem ja
also wir haben mitarbeiter des
ordnungsamtes und was eine stadt wie
baesweiler ausmacht haben viele
mitarbeiter anderer ämter die spontan
bereit waren das ordnungsamt bei diesen
kontrollen zu unterstützen und das
gelingt jetzt ist es ja ihre aufgabe als
bürgermeister nicht nur politisch dazu
führt zu sorgen das hat alles in bahnen
läuft dann hat ja irgendwie auch die
aufgabe die menschen dort hoffnungsvoll
zustimmen die gemeinde aufzufangen in so
einer schwierigen zeit wie machen sie
das und wie kann das alles bei den
menschen an
also wir machen das denke ich sehr
intensiv zum beispiel bei den kontrollen
der personen in quarantäne gibt es sehr
intensive gespräche auch unter dem
aspekt hoffnung machen wie auch die
gespräche mit den gastronomen mit den
einzelhändlern aber auch mit den bürgern
vor ort die presse trägt sehr gut dazu
bei und unserer homepage und andere
möglichkeiten also der kontakt der
bürger ist zu den bürgern ist sehr
intensiv gegeben haben sie denn
befürchtungen dass ihre stadt auch
wirtschaftlich von den folgen stark
betroffen sein wird
also wir machen uns die sorge wie denke
ich hege stadt nicht nur in der aachener
region sondern auch in vielen anderen
regionen wenn es zu einem kompletten
lockdown kommt wäre das natürlich ein
riesenproblem für alle stellte für alle
einzelhändler für alle gastronomen
wir hoffen dass dies uns alle erspart
bleibt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren